I think the lack of Chinese transparency
is the real story here that it clearly
exacerbated the problem and made its
distribution around the world
dramatically more likely that of course
is the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell as America ratchets up
pressure on the international community
hold China's government accountable for
this coronavirus outbreak Fox News has
learned Beijing has launched a campaign
now to punish coronavirus patients and
their family members the government is
targeting people who report contracting
new cases speak about being infected or
even try to mourn the death of a kovat
19 patient our correspondent Gillian
Turner is live in Washington with the
breaking details
good morning Gillian good morning Edie
so we have learned that the Chinese
government has indeed launched a
crackdown targeting coronavirus
survivors as well as family members in
China who have lost loved ones to the
pandemic now national security sources
tell us this is really just the latest
in the Communist Party's ongoing efforts
to cover-up the early days of the
outbreak inside we hon the number of
cases inside that city that's the
epicenter as well as the true extent of
the viruses spread across the rest of
China the crackdown against the bereaved
includes online censorship shuttering
down support groups police
interrogations and even threats against
lawyers who are representing Chinese
victims Secretary of Defense Esper says
it's all part of a very clear pattern to
try and save face at the expense of
people's lives take a listen they need
to still allow us in to talk to early
patients to talk to the Chinese
researchers and scientists and to have
access what are they doing they're
trying to capitalize on this by
promoting their own image that somehow
China is the good guy here the crackdown
is particularly tough inside Wuhan the
epicenter of the virus outbreak back in
December the New York Times was first to
report that officials there have also
been paying off family member
to the tune of 420 US dollars per member
lost to the pandemic China's ambassador
to the USO is pushing back today in a
new op-ed he accuses u.s. politicians of
scapegoating China in order to distract
from their own failures
he writes behind the mindset of always
blame China is a kind of dirty politics
championed by a few who shift the
spotlight for political gain
now as the US and the international
community ramps up pressure on China's
government on the Chinese Communist
Party to come clean and be held
accountable for the spread of the virus
our national security sources say that
this is an important reminder to point
out to folks that the Chinese people
Chinese citizens are also hungry for
accountability and for the government to
account for how they manage the crisis
during the early early days of the
outbreak yeah a lot of people looking
for accountability Gillian Turner thank
you